dans ces conditions est-ce que les
policiers légendaires notamment la loi
depuis 2017 augmentent leur intervention
pour tirer la réponse est non là encore
je veux dire que dans le débat qu'on a
eu c'est faux c'est pas parce qu'un
policier n'aurait pas respecté 2017 que
il y a eu une augmentation comme je l'ai
lu par 5 des tirs en zone police comme
en zone gendarmerie
en 2013 c'est le dernier enfin le
chiffre est plutôt que j'ai
226 déclarations de tir opérationnelle
et accidentelle de manière générale
usage sur véhicule en mouvement 133
en 2016 donc au moment où j'imagine le
gouvernement de ce Cazeneuve a été
inspiré pour prendre sa législation 255
tirs administratifs 313
usages de larmes volontaires
opérationnels en police en gendarmerie
181 sur véhicule en mouvement
en 2017 l'année de la loi 394 tirs
opérationnels 313 pardon 429 pardon
usage de l'inventaire opérationnelle et
sur les véhicules mouvements 255 prenons
l'exemple alors 2020 c'est une année
covid me paraît pas une bonne
comparaison mais 2021 qui était une
année covid à moitié 290 opérationnels
usages volontaires opérationnels 201 sur
les clients mouvements 2022 qui est une
année pleine sans covid 285 déclarations
de tir opérationnels 317 usages de armes
opérationnels 168 véhicules à mouvement
c'est à dire que l'apprentissage
gendarmerie c'est le contraire de ce
qu'on raconte il y a de plus en plus de
tempérés et j'utilise de moins en moins
leurs armes ça c'est la vérité des
chiffres et j'ai le détail police et
gendarmerie si vous le souhaitez
monsieur le sénateur je voulais passerai
c'est exactement la même chose dans les
deux façons il n'y en a pas une qui
augmente et une qui baisse c'est deux
baisse
donc je crois que on peut se poser des
questions encore une fois mis à
l'intérieur devant
l'incroyable force qu'on les force de
l'ordre par définition et la
contraratégie que nous console Parlement
peut se poser toutes les questions qu'il
faut après vous êtes d'accord avec moi
que la loi que vous venez de voter n'a
pas encore connu ses effets puisque nous
sommes dans la première année budgétaire
de cette transformation et encore une
fois nous avons augmenté de 4 mois la
formation c'est remonter d'un tiers nous
avons augmenté de 50% la formation
continue mais je veux dire que la police
et la gendarmerie contrairement à ce que
j'ai entendu et c'est tout à fait faux
ne tire pas plus qu'avant et oui les
réseaux tempérées augmente bien plus
qu'avant ça pose des tas de questions
les gens qui conduisent sans permis les
gens qui viennent de cambrioler les gens
qui ont de la drogue les gens qui ont de
l'alcool les gens qui respectent plus
aucune autorité c'est tout à fait vrai
il y a sans doute beaucoup de raisons
assez refaire mais il n'est pas vrai
quand j'ai lu et relu et relu que nous
augmenterions les consignes de tir de
les tirs les consignes et donc les tirs
sur les refuses sur les reflux